Ladies and gentlemen,
Kevin Belk
and Mr. Michael Moore.
So welcome to the toxic Google everyone.
I'm Kevin Belk.
Is Mr. Moore.
Just introduce me and this is Michael Moore,
film maker.
Documentarian document it.
Document documentary film maker is,
yeah,
documentary,
uh,
you know,
writer,
producer of all this and know that word.
Which one?
Documentarian.
Yeah,
I know.
I can say it.
You don't,
you don't like call Scorsese a fiction.
Attarian that's true.
So it's like I choose nonfiction.
The others choose fiction.
But you're,
we're filmmakers.
I wish,
I want,
I've been trying to drive this home to more documentary filmmakers and it if
they made documentaries as movies and that his documentaries more people,
Michael,
watch them.
That is true.
So,
you know,
it's,
um,
it's all about what we're going to do on Friday night,
right?
I apologize.
No,
no,
don't apologize.
I don't know.
I'm just,
you'll see you have a series of films,
Michael Born today and receive an official apology from Google
you a series of films so that your new film,
uh,
where to invade next.
This comes after Roger mean the awful truth.
Bowling for Columbine Fahrenheit.
Nine 11.
Sicko capitalism,
a love story.
So many of us,
don't forget Canadian Bacon and Canadian Bacon.
All right.
Many of us saw the film just now,
but can you just go into what the film was about and where the idea came from?
Well,
I've had this idea probably since I was nine
teen.
Oh,
I wasn't a filmmaker then.
I was just a kid with a youth hostel card and a Eurail pass and uh,
went over to Europe.
I'm one of those $99 flights and a backpack for two months and saw,
saw the way it was elsewhere,
Ben here and every country I would go to,
I would say,
God,
that's such a good idea of the way they do that.
Why don't we do that?
Or you know,
well that's so simple and so obvious.
You know,
it's like,
and,
and every time I've prattled since I was 19,
I've had this thought wherever I was in the world that there's always like this
really good little idea.
And how can we don't just steal that idea.
We're,
we're good at evading and you know,
trying to get other things.
Why don't we,
why don't we just like take some good ideas and bring them back to the u s so,
so I probably been thinking about this for a very long time and,
uh,
um,
and finally,
uh,
this year I decided to,
to do it.
And,
um,
and uh,
so I called up some friends that had made those films with me.
And,
um,
so why don't we,
why don't we go shoot this movie and let's just see what we find.
So why is this come now versus,
you know,
your first film?
What,
what,
what was the difference between,
oh,
now I've got to do it.
My,
uh,
because I think we're,
I think we're in a,
in a,
in a fairly perilous time,
in a moment here where things are going to shift one way or the other.
And I think that they've been moving somewhat in a good direction lately.
But,
um,
I'm printing here how to explain this because,
okay,
let's go back to 1999.
I'm directing a video for a rage against the machine down on Wall Street.
And,
um,
and so we're,
we're going to run over and we're going to try and,
you know,
break into the Stock Exchange essentially.
That's the conceit of the video.
And,
um,
and so we needed like stockbroker types and hedge fund guys.
And,
um,
so we had this,
this crowd of extras and I'm thinking there's,
they need to be holding signs or something.
So I went over to the art person,
I said here at makeup assignment says this.
And she goes,
and she gives it to the guy and this 1999 and the science says Trump for
president.
And
not saying it was my idea,
supplemental lesson.
Well,
I just thought wouldn't be the craziest thing
then I can come up with,
oh,
so,
but now it's not so funny anymore.
Now it's real.
Now he's going to be the Republican nominee for president of the United States.
And it's like,
oh,
see that?
Did you see there his rally in Massachusetts last night?
It was like a football stadium of people.
It was,
it was,
it was America,
Uber,
Alice.
It was,
it was really,
um,
wow.
Now I don't believe he can win,
but,
um,
I,
I don't think anybody should take them for granted.
People have been and the whole time it,
yes,
me too.
And it would start off as a joke now it's like,
oh crap.
But like people are following them.
So it seems like no matter what he says too,
and not to get off complete topic,
but I remember what he says,
just seems to be like,
Oh,
I'm just said it and they just goes on.
So how is that working for him?
Works?
Well,
one thing that people do like about him is that he doesn't think before he
talks,
which was like most of us.
So He seems kind of real in that way where he just says whatever's on his mind.
And it feels refreshing because we're so used to the political speak and,
and he's,
he's,
he too was interested in it and he's saying things he doesn't believe in.
So at the beginning of this year,
I thought,
well,
this is just really good performance art because,
uh,
if you've lived in New York for any period of time or if you are a native New
Yorker,
you know,
you don't Trump.
And you know that he,
um,
you know,
has funded a,
uh,
all these different campaigns and groups for gay marriage for a pro choice,
for,
uh,
guns.
I mean the whole,
I mean,
he's been very liberal on all the,
all the issues through most of his,
his,
his life.
He's very pro union,
at least the private sector unions.
Uh,
he wants to raise the minimum wage has always been for that.
He's always been for a,
and he,
and I think he still a one time tax on the rich of 14%,
where they literally would have to pay 40% of what they own right now.
But this would,
in his mind,
retire the debt.
He's for single payer health care,
not dot for the right reasons,
but because it all we're doing with those 50,
there's 50 state insurance commissioners,
red tape everywhere.
You know,
it's like we just need,
we just need one,
one insurance commissioner,
single prayer.
And uh,
you know,
it's like,
uh,
so,
so on that level,
you know,
that he's faking it and his time on television sort of blurred the line in his
own mind between reality and,
and,
and TD or performance and,
and now,
and he's now he sees it works for him.
He sees by being a Demigod,
by being a,
by being a racist,
by being a kind of pro fascist,
uh,
that there's always a crowd for that.
And history has proven,
there's always been a crowd for that.
And so,
but,
but the good news is,
is that 81% of the people of this country are either women people of color or
adults between the ages of 18 and 35.
That's 81% of America.
That's not the America he sees.
He thinks they are all guys that look like him,
but the white guys over 35 or 19% of the population.
So,
so he's speaking to a very small group.
And the reason he shouldn't and can't win is because the majority of the country
are dames or broads,
uh,
people he wants to build a wall around or people your age who probably don't
find him to.
Cool.
And I'm just,
I'm just saying I'm not,
I mean,
I haven't surveyed everybody in here,
but I'm just guessing that when you think of somebody representing you to the
rest of the world,
the image of Trump doesn't come into your mind.
Um,
but,
but we are also the slacker side of the political arena,
our side of the fence,
my side of the fence,
you know,
the other side,
they're going to be up on election morning,
six in the morning,
they're going to vote.
Right.
The only reason we'd be up at six in the morning as if we partied all night,
you know,
so it's like,
right.
So it's like,
so,
so if enough people don't get involved,
if the,
if the Democratic candidate is an inspiring,
doesn't create the enthusiasm that Obama did,
you know,
it was just kind of zone like that.
Um,
and just talks like a politician.
Enough people may stay home.
Certainly enough young people when they stay home and enough people of color may
stay home.
And that's really something to think about.
It's why and all those polls.
What's interesting is that Hillary is ahead of,
uh,
Bernie,
um,
you know,
in the,
in the main number.
But when you pit them against Trump,
in the recent polls,
Bernie has come out of pointed to a head when it's Hillary versus Trump or
Bernie versus Trump.
So it's something to,
it's something to think about.
I know this has nothing to do with this.
No,
no,
but how did we get on that?
Uh,
it was because you called me a documentarian and uh,
but no,
so I mean,
but,
but I can kind of tie this into segue into a social media because you kind of,
you very,
very much embrace that with Twitter.
You did that stint at Trump tower with we all Muslim.
And so you fully embrace social media.
How has that kind of changed you and giving yourself another voice in this
medium kind of,
you didn't really grow up with it,
but now you have it as a,
as a platform.
Oh,
I know,
but as soon as it came,
I was the,
I had a TV show in 1993,
92,
95 called TV nation.
It was on NBC and then it was on Fox,
a good fox,
Simpson's Fox,
not Fox News.
Um,
but the,
um,
but I was the first prime time television show to actually have at the,
in the credits at the end of the show,
www dot.
An actual website.
Nobody had ever done that before.
And they were like,
the network was like,
why do you want put that in there?
I said,
because of this is really,
this is 1999 93 now.
Right.
So it's,
it's not really,
it's not a thing yet,
but I,
I immediately saw social media as,
as the smasher of the wall between the people and,
and the rest of the people.
There's,
there's always,
there's always been a wall where if we wanted to communicate to each other,
how would we do that?
You know,
I remember something I didn't like.
It was written in the New Yorker magazine and my only option as it was for like
a,
if you read something in the paper or whatever was to write a letter to the
editor,
maybe they would publish it,
maybe not in its original form.
I wrote this to the New Yorker and they wrote back and said,
where they,
we don't have letters to the editor.
And I thought,
wow.
So they just published something about my hometown of Flint,
Michigan.
That wasn't true.
And I have no means to correct the record in a,
in a,
in a valued in and sophisticated publication like the New Yorker.
And I just,
I thought,
wait,
this is way back then.
God,
I wish there was some way where I could leap over the gatekeeper and just let
everybody know.
Actually,
here's the truth.
The fact that that social media has allowed us to talk to each other,
that it can,
that we can't be regulated or stopped from doing that and that and that,
those empower camp,
they can get away with things still.
And they certainly try,
but it's a lot harder for them,
witnessed the police who simply cannot just,
you know,
randomly get away with now it makes you wonder how many other innocent people
and by people I,
that's a euphemism for black and Hispanic people,
but people,
black and Hispanic people who had been,
who had been killed by police and we never knew that.
That's just one example of how,
of how the democratization and the,
and the sort of,
um,
egalitarianism of social media and that and that,
it doesn't matter that if I'm,
I'm a filmmaker,
I,
you know,
I'm with Warner Brothers or whatever that you can talk to me.
You can,
you can send me an email tonight.
you can tweet at me,
you can go on my Facebook page and I go there and I read it and,
and I will randomly write back to people.
I mean,
I obviously,
I can't write the thousand that may see this and,
and write me,
but I,
I do what I can do,
but I certainly,
I certainly get a sense of what people are saying.
I never would have got that sense before.
So this is such a,
a great era.
And I,
and I don't think,
I mean a lot of people my age,
and I can't believe there's still people,
boom,
baby boomers and the such or are still like,
like this,
you know,
torn.
It's like,
oh my God,
you're going to end up like both of my grandmothers never learned how to drive a
car.
They thought the horse was going to come back.
I mean,
I'm like,
you know,
oh,
you're so crazy to stay away from this.
And,
and then they,
and then they point out the things that bother them.
Like I came in here and I counted five people that were on their devices while
my movie was going on.
And I'm like,
okay.
But then I'm like,
but you know,
but that's,
but I'd rather deal with that than not have this.
And,
and,
and who knows how many lives that those five were saving in here?
No,
no,
but it's,
it's,
um,
it,
it's,
it's a good thing and it's an,
and we can't even imagine now.
I remember I was at the 2004 Democratic convention and Jimmy Carter,
I was just there kind of co,
I was covering it actually for a paper.
And,
um,
it was after fair nine,
nine 11 came out and he asked if I would like to sit in the presidential box
with him on the Nike was going to give his speech.
And I was like,
wow,
yes,
thank you.
And,
um,
and in the box,
we're a two or two of the three.
The founders,
the people that you know,
you know,
started this and uh,
and uh,
they were,
it was,
it was like,
I just remember,
I still remember this moment because Google in 2004 was how many,
how many years old?
Two years old.
Like five,
six every six months.
Yeah.
But I mean,
okay,
yes.
But yes,
the incorporation papers were filed and people started with the hype around,
but I'm turning and I mean in a sense,
in the sense that it,
that everybody was using it.
That was the early,
that was the infancy right of,
of go.
And I just remember thinking this is such a great moment.
And I was thinking as I was standing up here with everybody,
we don't even know 10 years from now what is going to be
invented or how,
what better ways we're going to have to talk to each other reaching.
So I think it's revolutionary.
I think that this can create,
um,
uh,
movements.
It can involve people more in their democracy.
It has so many good things about it.
And the bad things about it are,
are,
are regulated by other people.
So if you put out something out there that's not true,
there's going to be a thousand people on you to correct the why that you're
telling.
You know,
it's interesting though,
because I think with this film you did it very much in secret.
So you can,
you kind of shut off social media.
You didn't let a publicist come on with you.
And it's very much done in secret.
So no press release was sent out when we did the deal and we,
and we did,
we didn't disconnect.
I didn't disconnect from social media in terms of politics or news or things
that were going on,
but I wasn't going to discuss what I was doing.
Certainly the one thing you learn,
how many times do you have to be burned on Google to know there are just so many
things you want to share.
So,
so that was an easy one,
uh,
to do.
But we knew we would tweet about this and we would put this up and we Instagram
it when we were done.
But,
uh,
what was interesting is that we were able to get away with it that,
um,
and I don't know,
in 10 years we would be 10 years from now that we'll be able to get away with
it.
Part of it's a language issue.
Maybe somebody saw me in Slovenia and,
and tweeted in Slovenian,
but you were there.
But you know,
there's not a lot out there yet for people to kind of,
I mean,
the mechanisms exist to translate that,
but it's,
it's,
I'm,
I'm more concerned with the fact that we would be the top story on the evening
news and in Italy or France or whatever,
because they were,
they would see me filming and saw the camera crews would come out,
interview me,
but,
you know,
it would be,
it would,
you know,
the whole broadcast was an Italian or Slovenian.
And because the networks no longer have these foreign bureaus,
you know,
if they're,
if they're maybe a big one of the big three networks.
So the New York Times,
they've got somebody in London,
they've got somebody in Tokyo.
But in the old days,
guys,
in my time,
man,
there was somebody in Paris,
Madrid,
Rome,
Warsaw,
it was everywhere and now and now corporate media that doesn't exist.
So,
right.
And so in,
in where to invade next,
you visit Italy,
France,
Finland,
Germany,
Slovenia,
not Slovakian,
Portugal,
Tonasia,
Norway and Iceland.
Um,
so how did you choose which countries would be included and were there any that
you did film or you thought about doing and then just pull the way?
Yes.
Um,
we,
we filmed three countries that we didn't put in the film.
Okay.
Mainly because I don't think movies should be longer than two hours.
Um,
I think most movies are too long anyways.
Don't you agree?
And if they are longer than two hours and they should really earn it like right.
Um,
so I didn't mind star wars,
you know,
being longer than two hours.
So,
um,
but I,
uh,
we went to Canada,
we went to Austria and we went also to Estonia and Astonia because they,
uh,
they have the best mother mortality rate.
Uh,
the least number of mothers die in childbirth and slow in Estonia than any other
country.
Austria has lowered the voting age to 16 as half a dozen or half a dozen other
countries.
And they found that 18 to 30 year olds voted a higher percentage when you get
them starting to vote in high school.
Um,
I think that's a really,
really good idea,
especially if they're going to be fighting in a war,
God forbid,
ever again in this country.
But you know,
there are a lot of things you're going to have to start doing at 18 and maybe in
a couple of years leading up to that,
you should have a say in what's going to happen to you at 18 and a lot of 16
year olds are not mature enough.
They won't bother,
they won't vote.
But the ones who are engaged,
why not have there,
why not give them a say in their early adulthood?
Right.
Um,
I mean there's so much interesting stuff in here,
but your goal was,
it paints a very,
very good picture of each of these countries too.
And you had said,
you know,
it was not to present a complete portrait of each of the countries,
but they kind of pick out things that they do well and that folks signing the
negative and none of it was actually shot in the u s she didn't know every,
we wanted to make a film about the u s but not shoot a single frame of film in
the u s that was,
that was kind of our challenge at the beginning.
Could that be possible?
And uh,
and tell the story of America by going to these other countries.
And I wasn't and I only wanted to take the guy,
why would I want to take a bad thing?
You know,
and I'll go to buy a new car and buy a clunker.
I want to get a car that works.
So I don't want,
I don't want any of that.
All of these countries have things that don't work.
Right.
Um,
but that's not my mission.
My mission was gold.
Take the things that work really well and bring them here because I think most
of those things could work here.
Some of them will be harder because we haven't dealt with are our racial
question yet.
Uh,
but uh,
but some of those things,
we can stop poisoning kids during the lunch hour tomorrow.
You know,
every parent that sees this film can go to the PTA meeting next week and say,
Hey,
you know what?
Why don't we,
why don't we do this differently?
They do this in France differently and it costs less.
Right.
I mean,
that's,
that's one of the great things.
It was the second country visit,
which was France,
which is basically going in to these children's elementary school and seeing
what they serve for lunch,
which are basically at these gourmet meals.
There's four course meals with cheese and lamb skewers and all that,
and just amazing,
amazing stuff.
And they meet.
So the head chef or school will meet with a school officials.
Yes.
The answer to the mayor and the school officials and the township,
right.
Dietitian.
And so we loved about that.
You imagine it,
but if the people that fed us,
especially if you went to public school,
people have fed us at lunch,
were,
had the answer to a Dietitian.
It was be like a firing squad.
And you know,
Michelle Obama tried to start that,
but it kind of got some pushback and wasn't really working.
So why didn't that work?
That's kind of seems like the country is moving more towards at least it seems
like a little bit more of the healthy stuff with what?
With us,
you have to do it differently.
I think you have to,
you have to do help health wise.
But you call it pizza,
no matter,
no matter what you make or what you feed them the day.
Don't call it lamb skewers,
just call it pizza.
And I just think of,
we trust rename everything pizza,
but make it really good and tasty.
All right.
It does have to taste good,
but it tastes good and still be and still be healthy.
Um,
these,
but it's funny with these kids because they don't drink coke,
you know,
they,
first of all,
they were,
they looked at it like it was poison.
Then finally the little girl next to me.
Right.
I hope I didn't bully her too much.
I know every time I watch that scene I want to call child protective services on
me.
It's like I keep pushing on the glass and then she tries it and within 15
seconds,
you know her,
she was like this with her fork and I was like,
cause she's,
I'm thinking here's,
she's never had this.
Now she's taking too big of a gulp and literally has mainlined it right into our
system.
It was this,
it was a,
it's a sad,
sad scene.
Well,
I'm embarrassed.
I'm like,
there's just some great scenes and some great interesting things that you pull
from each country.
I'm like in Italy,
how much vacation they get.
I think it was something like 30,
35 days of paid vacation plus another week of national holiday.
Yep.
15 days of paid holiday after getting married.
Yup.
13 months salary in December.
Just here's a month salary.
Just pure it is for you.
Yeah.
Because what's the use of having a vacation if you can't pay for it?
Right.
I mean,
most people live from paycheck to paycheck.
So what if they give you four weeks off?
Well fine,
but I gotta pay my mortgage that month.
I got to pay the car payment,
I got to pay the school,
I've got to pay,
you know,
how am I going to pay?
I'm not going to go anywhere.
So they,
they,
they worked that into the system.
Right.
And it was interesting because you talked about,
you kind of were oppressing them a little bit on the American dream and like,
Oh,
if you come to America,
you only get zero,
you get zero unless you go into an employer who actually pay for itself.
And they were like,
oh.
So the American dream kind of a little bit changed for them where they were
like,
I don't know if I want to go.
Right.
Well they know,
they think they all know America a lot by the movies and you know,
it,
look,
we look good in the movies generally.
So I think they go in France the day that let's say you're going to move,
you got to new apartment,
you're going to move from queens to Brooklyn.
That's a step up right now.
Okay.
I'm from Michigan.
So,
um,
but um,
uh,
the day you moved from Queens to Brooklyn,
if you were in France,
that's a paid day off by law.
You should not have to miss your pay because you got to move.
So if you got to move tomorrow,
then a,
you shouldn't have to lose any money because you had to move.
I mean,
that just,
it's just little things like that.
You just go,
wow,
that's kind of humane.
Well,
it was interesting in a lot of it.
I mean,
there's time,
interesting things in here,
but some of these were actually American ideas and they brought that up a few
times and that where it was like in Finland with,
um,
you know,
a free tuition and,
and only three to four hours of school a day with a lunch hour and getting rid
of standardized tests that we have here in America.
And,
um,
you know,
and there's no good or bad schools,
they're just,
the rich kids are mixed in with the poor kids in the middle class and everyone
goes to school together and it's actually illegal to actually charge tuition.
So,
you know,
with,
uh,
some of these illegal to charge tuition,
can you believe that?
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Even for college,
I said,
don't treat me you don't have a Harvard and the minister of Education,
she says we have 19 Harvard's
okay.
Right.
And like the Norwegian prison.
So you know how they treat their,
their prisoners like humans,
like humans,
and they have to treat them because there's no life sentence and there's no
capital punishment.
So they get a lecture from the warden and day one it says,
because we don't have these two things that America has,
that means you may be my neighbor someday,
you may be living on my street.
So it's in my best interest for that.
When you leave here that you leave,
you're a better person and not inclined to commit crime.
So it's,
so,
it's not just because of the Norwegians are better than us.
They have,
there's a self interest involved in wanting to live in a safer society.
Well and they're very free there.
I mean for,
you guys just saw the film,
it's its crazy cause it's there,
it's almost like a resort where they go to and it's very free and open.
They could swim across the lake,
they can spend one way,
they can't swim and it's,
it's very open.
They have the keys to their own doors.
And even the cool thing was I was like,
oh this is this gotta be fake.
But then you went to the maximum security prison.
I was like,
oh that was interesting because that was even free to,
it's a little more protected or guarded,
but it was very,
very,
um,
open and free.
And they had TV and they had internet and it was,
it was just crazy.
But again,
he said this was one of the,
what the guards were saying that it was,
you know,
this is an American idea where it was basically no cruel punishment towards the
prisoners and stuff.
So where do we lose our way?
Or where did we lose work?
Where are they getting that can actually,
cause America obviously hasn't done that for years.
So where are they getting this from?
Is this just from the pastor or,
well,
the world for a very long time has loved the United States of America and is
looked up to us and,
and they,
they know that there's some,
there's a certain thing about us and our,
our ingenuity and are sort of motivation and are,
and we're kind of all like this,
you know,
and they're very much playing it close to the chest and,
and
they know that,
you know,
belled Belgium isn't going to invent the iPhone,
no offense to Belgium.
Um,
Google isn't going to come out of Hungary,
no offense to hungry.
But there is something unique about us that,
um,
that historically we'd been this sort of,
and part of it is,
is the,
is the classless society that we've always tried to say we are trying to be.
Um,
but I think that there's so many good things about us that they admire and they
bought a lot of it and we decided to start buying it.
Uh,
we had an education system that was the envy of the world.
Now nobody would want our education system.
Nobody,
nobody would come here to study it.
So they just took all the great progressive,
philosophical American education ideas and just implemented them.
Um,
in Germany and Japan and Italy,
the Axis powers during world war two,
after the war,
after they were defeated,
President Roosevelt,
he had just passed away.
Um,
but he had set it up so that when the war ended,
um,
uh,
his,
his team from his administration would go and write their new constitutions.
So in the new constitutions for Germany and Italy and Japan,
they had universal healthcare.
They have labor rights.
They had,
you know,
um,
the college and education being a free and progressive system.
So they institute a lot of the things we didn't have.
Even then,
the part of our past that we're not,
that we shouldn't be proud of in terms of our racial issue,
um,
how we've treated our native people.
Um,
how we've allowed capitalism to morph itself into an ugly system of greed and,
and making sure that only the very,
very,
very top get all the,
the wealth and everybody else scrambles for the crumbs.
Um,
you know,
that's,
there's nothing to look back and be proud of in that part of our history.
So it's kind of a,
it's,
I feel bad that we've lost our way in that sense.
I mean,
I want to know,
looking at you in this room,
I was just trying to add up the total amount of student loan debt,
uh,
in this room.
I'm sure it's in the millions.
Um,
but my generation,
your parents,
um,
we went to school for free or nearly free depending on where you lived.
You know,
if you went to,
if your parents went to Brooklyn College,
they paid $35 a semester.
If they went to UC Berkeley,
they went for free.
If they went to Suny Buffalo,
Uh,
if they went to Anarbor,
I dunno,
they paid 500 bucks.
It was nothing.
Right?
Why did we allow a system to come into being
that Ben sent you as 22 year olds out into the world as debtors,
as it in a debtor's prison,
as I said in the film.
Well,
why would we do that to our own kids?
Why did we let that happen?
Why did we let the banks and the whole system a lot,
why did we,
why did we not give you what we had?
Well,
how do you,
how do you change that?
How you go back like,
like it seems like we're too deep in.
It does seem that way and I know and some of it seems a little hopeless.
I,
well
there's many examples I can give where it seemed hopeless and eventually women
could vote.
You know,
it seemed hopeless and eventually,
I mean,
hopeless was going back to,
oh,
for the election when 14 states made it part of the constitution.
Okay.
To make it illegal.
To marry the person you're in love with.
Okay.
If they happened to be of the same gender,
here we are,
11 years later gone.
It's like,
wow.
You know,
like I said in the film,
it's okay.
The impossible can happen,
right?
Because this was a country bigoted against gay and lesbian people and then all
of a sudden it wasn't illegal to be in love.
And if that can happen,
I just,
I think practically anything can happen.
And I,
and there are some good groups that can show how we can go back to free college
education,
at least for the state schools.
Will we ever have a system where uh,
there won't be private schools and you can't charge for tuition?
I would probably doubt that,
but we can certainly make the,
our state institutions to be,
um,
either very affordable or free for all the students.
And it wouldn't cost that much more money to do that.
We spent 750 billion on defense.
You know,
if we just cut that back by a third,
that money could be used for so many good things.
Why don't we have a bullet train from New York to La?
We are,
we in the Brits invented the train.
Why does Taiwan have a bullet train?
Go Google the map of Taiwan right now on the northern for if you went from the
east coast of the west coast of northern Taiwan,
you could walk it in a day.
They don't need a bullet train.
They have a bullet train.
We have 3000 miles.
We need a bullet train.
You know,
we can afford that if we want it to do that.
Why don't we have that?
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
we used to be the innovators.
We used to do this.
I was telling the,
my saw my crew,
we came in here today.
I said,
you know,
this building has a very important history.
You guys all know the history of this building right now.
For those of you who are watching or listening elsewhere,
we're in the original port authority building here.
Uh,
that goes between ninth avenue and Eighth Avenue and 15th and 16th Street.
Um,
by the way,
those are not,
I'm not giving coordinates out to the Trump campaign fire priority missiles at
this moment.
But,
um,
but the original cable that was laid under the Atlantic Ocean,
the first cable that to bring the towel first,
the Telegraph,
and then the telephone line came up out of the Atlantic Ocean and Undergrad and
up into this building and from here,
whatever the call or the telegraph was or whatever,
emanated from this building that out to wherever across North America that
that's,
that's an amazing thing when you think back to it and you know,
you've,
you've read,
read the book tubes about,
you know,
the Internet,
remember the Republican senator who was add to a bunch of damn tubes,
but then this journalist thought,
well,
you don't actually,
there's are a lot of tubes involved here and the I and sort of the sweet irony
that Google now inhabits this building,
that the virtual tube that we're all connected to,
um,
in,
it's so much better and easier way than friend to bring a call or a telegraph
and from the Atlantic Ocean that you're in this building.
I think it's,
it's very cool.
Yeah.
Uh,
we'll start taking audience questions if you guys wanna start lining up the mic.
Um,
but you know,
one of,
one of the things that when we were sitting here watching the film on things
that got the biggest laugh and got the biggest circle out of me was the cause.
We all know it too well,
which is in Germany where they have basically when work is over,
it's over and they don't bring it home with them and it's against the law to,
of contact an employee while they're on vacation.
And many companies have adopted the rule that companies can't send any emails
after work hours such as Mercedes,
where they actually have computers that blocked the emails sent by bosses to
their reports were those,
was that laughter you heard or whales and bones and Christ.
It was so interesting because I mean that,
I mean they've changed the entire way they even work in there really.
The countries are caring about their people more,
right?
Versus just trying to make a buck or whatever the case may be.
Right.
Social media should not be used to abuse employees.
Social media is there to help us be better people in a better world,
not for an employer to have a tether on you until midnight.
And,
uh,
and I just think that just seems like common sense,
decent,
um,
you know,
behavior and it's your choice if you want to do that,
do that.
I mean if you knew the employee want to work,
you know,
but again,
it's,
you need to also take some time for yourself and you need to not work at some
point.
Let me,
can I ask you just,
I'm going,
whoa.
I mean,
cause this is an interesting question because like the,
the uh,
the maternity leave,
the paid you guys,
I'm sure I've read,
you know,
you and,
and uh,
and,
Facebook and a lot of the social media giants have really good,
uh,
plans in terms of if you're going to have a baby or,
or,
um,
you know,
how much time you can take off.
And in fact,
yeah,
some,
I don't know who it is.
Somebody just,
you could have unlimited time.
Netflix.
Netflix is,
I can that be our like are they,
are they shitting me or when they are and they like,
or because I can imagine that would just make it worse because then you don't
know when or how much you could take off or how much are they going to hate me
or the boss is going to,
I'm going to get the worst job when I come back.
Or I'm like,
you know,
is that an issue?
Like even in a place here where you have to think about,
I think in general,
just in America,
I think it's just any company that I've been at where it's just you do feel that
pressure where it's like,
oh,
I do want to take two weeks after I get married.
I want to take a week here a week.
They're like,
but it is very much in terms of American culture,
just disconnecting in general and just trying to break away and not feel guilty
for doing that sometimes.
So enough about me.
Yup.
Hi there.
Um,
so I think,
I mean,
you can correct me if I'm wrong,
but I think a lot of us would agree that America has some of the best
innovations,
especially in the tech sector,
um,
you know,
in the whole world.
Um,
so I was wondering if you thought that if America was to adopt some of the
policies like in Europe,
if you think that that would stifle some of the innovations that are coming out
of America.
No,
and in fact,
I just said,
you know what I just said,
I,
I do believe that's one of the things that's really great about us.
What would it,
when you say stifled,
like you mean the vacation thing or the or what?
Like what,
what do they have that would stifle us here?
I'm not sure exactly,
but I know I've looked around at,
you know,
Europe just doesn't have,
if you look at like tech startups,
there's not that many in Europe.
And I can sure if some of it might be that like it's already established in the
u s but I imagine that it might just be a little bit harder and more expensive
to start a business there.
Yeah,
well that now that I don't know about,
but I think that just imagine though if you had,
if you actually had a few weeks to not have to worry about work,
how many people in this room have had an idea that if you just had a little time
to explore the idea or investigate it,
the noodle with it to go into whatever your version of the workshop is for you,
what great ideas or inventions are we not getting because you're,
there's so much pressure on you to be a certain way and to work a certain way
that doesn't allow that to come out.
That's what I would,
I'm more concerned about about that and I think that if we,
if we were a little more European,
just chilled a little more.
The creativity in us.
And I don't mean just inventing the next tech thing.
There is somebody in here that probably has got a great novel in them and or
screenplay or movie,
they'd like them or I,
you know,
whatever.
Maybe there be,
there's just a great poem that needs to be written in this room.
Uh,
you know,
are you allowing yourself to have the time to do that and the freedom to do
that?
And Are you having the chill to do that?
I,
um,
I guess I'm more concerned about that when you hear that they are more
regulations there,
there's a reason they do on some level and that's because they don't want you to
eat bad meat and they,
they want to make sure the products are,
are right.
And you know,
they have,
they're strict about certain things because they care about the people.
So they're really,
they're concerned about that.
They don't want polluters polluting,
things like that.
So,
but about those small businesses and all that,
I don't know much about.
Okay,
thanks.
Yeah.
And were you allowed to ask a question about Donald Trump or is it just
you are not allowed?
This is a matter of course.
You can ask me,
ask me anything you want.
Um,
I had a moment that you as a filmmaker might relate to.
I was for holidays,
I was in Europe and it was at a show and it was so enjoying and then I had all,
is it in this moment of,
this feels very much like the beginning of the Second World War movie that shows
Europe before the war that everybody is just enjoying the culture.
People are participating in opera and concert and everything and all of a sudden
the,
you know,
generals and called into an emergency meeting and a war is worth breaking out.
Um,
my point is why are we so comfortable with believing Trump has no chance.
What has have we as the world learn after Second World War and that we are so
confident in nutter,
fascist government is not going to come to power.
And another person like Hitler,
um,
who started all these ideas but bullying,
minority group,
what religious group,
um,
is not going to happen again.
Like nothing has seriously happened.
I'm going to still very strongly believing Donald Trump doesn't have a chance.
And I have been hearing that for the last six months and now solidly leading the
GOP.
The reason people think that he doesn't have a chance,
and I think you're okay to think that he doesn't have a chance.
It's because everybody knows the America we live in now and it's not angry white
guys like Donald Trump is the people.
I,
I said women generally aren't going to vote for Trump.
He's,
he's guaranteed that people of color,
uh,
are not going to vote there.
You can look at all the polls.
I mean,
I saw one poll where Hispanics,
it wasn't even 0%,
it was like a nightmare.
It was a negative number and I couldn't,
how do you get a negative number in a pool?
So it's,
it's,
and then,
and then young people,
you are the one good thing baby boomers and the,
and the next generation did in terms of who your parents are is,
I think that we raised a generation of people who don't hate,
you're not,
you're not haters.
You don't hate people because of their skin color.
You don't hate people because of who they are in love with.
And,
and we raised you.
And so it's,
it's,
it's very hard for,
uh,
the,
the protal fascist types to take charge.
It's like,
you know,
if women were voting,
would they vote for Hitler?
If,
if black people and Hispanics voted in mass,
would they vote for Hitler?
I mean,
not to use Hitler as the,
I only use it because you use that example.
But I'm just saying that,
that,
that it's nothing to be afraid of,
but we should be conscious of it.
And we should no longer treat him as a joke.
You should be taken seriously and,
and,
and dealt with.
Um,
and so I tweeted out yesterday when he,
when he said that about Bill Clinton was an abuser of women.
Well actually Bill Clinton gave us the family leave act,
so we don't have paid maternity leave,
but we have maternity leave now.
You can take so many weeks off.
Thanks to Bill Clinton.
He was pro choice.
Um,
he had consensual sex with an adult.
Okay.
Um,
and none of our business,
frankly.
Okay.
And then I just Hashtag uh,
Trump Trump's three wives,
um,
not that there's anything wrong with having three wives,
sometimes the third one is a charm.
And I,
I make,
I make no judgment about that.
I'm just saying I was just my way of putting it out there.
I'd love to hear from them,
you know,
because this guy can't get away with,
can't get away with that,
shouldn't get away with that.
And I'm not,
I'm not a healer.
I haven't endorsed anybody for president.
I'm just saying though,
that,
that if he's going to go down that road,
people who've got to stand up against this and that'd be both not be bullied.
Yes.
Thank you.
All right.
Uh,
so growing up in Australia,
I'm sorry,
I'm here now.
Right.
It felt strong cultural,
social,
economic connections to the u s there's a lot of similarities.
Uh,
I think it is.
There's the saying that a lot of European countries with Canada.
Um,
but I remember watching bowling for Columbine when I was 11 or 12 or something
and thinking what the Hell is wrong with this country?
What's so in the,
in this movie as well,
you've laid out a lot of the differences and a lot of the things that the US
does differently to these other countries.
Um,
and we can all see as differences around us education,
healthcare,
um,
guns.
What,
why is it the US is so different.
There's,
there's so much history,
cultural,
economic connection.
What do you think the reasons are for these differences?
Partly what I said in the phone,
because we haven't,
we have been able to deal with our two original sins that we were founded on
genocide and we were built on the backs of slaves.
We don't acknowledge it and we haven't fixed it as a real insult until we,
you got to take care of that first problem.
I think before he can move on and be a better people
kind of in Australia also had serious problems.
Uh,
well yes,
but nothing like us.
Nothing at all.
Like us.
Camera did not have a slave system like us and Britain and Canada ended slavery
before we did and and made reparations and the Canadians have continued to make
reparations to the native people.
In fact,
they gave them a whole province that they can autonomously run.
I can't imagine us doing that for native Americans or,
or you know,
even though as I show almost 40% of Mississippi is black and they have an in
what they get for that,
what they get for being 40% of the state are the most conservative redneck
representatives in Congress.
It makes absolutely no sense until you start to think about,
well how do you suppress the vote of 40 or 40% of the state's black?
How do you get the most conservative white people to represent the state?
I think,
I think that,
that,
um,
a lot of our problems as to do with fear.
Um,
we were easily manipulated with fear.
it's why we have so many guns,
I think in people's homes.
I mean,
why would you have a gun in the house?
You're afraid of something,
right?
You might need it for production production against whom?
Little freckle face.
Jimmy down the street.
I don't think so.
I don't think you were worried about Jimmy.
What are you worried about?
Why are 90% of the guns in homes or in suburbs and rural areas not in the city?
Why don't we have any mass shootings that are city high schools,
right?
It doesn't happen,
does it?
You know?
So I think that there's a lot that,
I mean,
I think there's a much longer answer to that,
but I think that there's,
there are things unique about us and President Obama,
you probably didn't see him today with his,
did you guys see it?
Uh,
his press conference on guns and what he's going to do,
he broke down and cried there.
I mean,
he's had tears before,
but I've never seen him.
He actually cried and he couldn't stop the tears.
He tried to stop them and they wouldn't stop once he started.
Once he,
he mentioned the,
the 26 year olds that were shot,
21st graders shot at new town.
He couldn't get the thought out of his head and he couldn't,
the tears couldn't stop coming down his face.
You'll see.
You'll see it later and you look it up.
That was crazy.
I did see that this morning.
And actually,
do you think the presidents executive action would,
is it going to change anything?
You know,
think nothing.
No,
no.
But his heart's in the right place.
He's a compassionate person.
Um,
he doesn't really have the power it needs to have to fix this,
but the biggest problem isn't the fact that,
you know,
they have guns in Canada and they don't,
they don't shoot each other like we do.
Um,
and they have guns and lots of countries.
Israel is a good example.
Lots of guns and Israel,
but they don't go to the high schools and shoot him up.
They don't shoot each other.
There's something very unique.
And he said during the talk today,
he says,
I don't think Americans are any more violent than other people.
Actually we are,
we are more violent,
were violent collectively.
By the way we invade countries,
the way we drone bomb civilians,
the things that we do,
um,
are shameful.
And personally the way we resolve our differences,
remember,
70%,
I think 60 to 70% of all murders are between people who know each other.
It's not a stranger killing you.
It's,
it's somebody you resolving a dispute whether somebody you're mad at and you
reach for the gun.
That's how most of our murders,
you know,
take place.
So,
um,
I'll give shorter answers seeing it more people for sure.
But it really quickly,
um,
would you ever revisit something in a film like you did with bowling for
Columbine now knowing where the country has gone with project?
No.
Sadly,
bowling for Columbine could open this Friday and be every bit as relevant as it
was in 2002.
That's a sad statement to me.
The only thing I would change about bowling for Columbine is I would mention
that we're safe from 51% of the population.
Women don't do this.
San Bernardino aside,
that's an incident that hasn't been explained yet.
So I'll wait on that.
But women don't do mass shootings.
Women,
uh,
don't go into high schools and spray bullets.
Um,
when you're walking home on eighth avenue here tonight,
stark your radars up a little bit because it's dark.
You're in a big city.
What are you afraid of?
The image in your mind is not a woman jumping out of the bushes to assault you.
It's a guy.
So let's just say what it is.
We're the,
the unsafe factor comes from the 49% of the population.
So,
so I would've,
I would've put a little happy news and bowling for Columbine to say that we're
actually safe from the majority of Americans.
Native Americans generally generally are not going to kill you or harm you in
that way.
Go women,
unless you're cheating her.
Michael,
thank you for the phone.
Yes.
Um,
what do you,
when you make a film,
and I guess,
you know,
thinking about your portfolio films,
what do you want those some dude,
I mean,
in terms of affecting change,
is it to start the dialogue?
Is it too,
the first thing I want to do is for you to have felt that you just spent a good
these two hours.
There was a good way to spend those two hours that I'm,
I'm filmmaker,
so I,
you go to the movies,
I want you to have a good time at the movies.
I want you to,
I want you to walk up the aisle going,
damn,
that was good.
That seriously,
that is as every film maker wants that first and foremost that at the very least
you were entertained in entertainment can mean it kept that was thought
provoking a,
but you laughed.
Maybe,
maybe you cried.
Um,
maybe you've got mad.
Any of those things.
Uh,
I'm happy with,
with all of that.
If 10% of the audience commits themselves to doing something about this,
that would be huge.
Um,
I don't expect that from everybody and I don't demand it.
I really,
I really want you to,
I want you to have a good time at the movies.
And so I make movies for you to take a date to on a Friday night.
You know,
I,
I'm serious.
I was signed in the edit room that says,
remember people want to go home and have sex after watching this movie.
It's like don't mess it up for them,
you know?
Well it seems like social media and how it allows things to be a little bit more
democratic and more feedback.
But at the same time,
over the years we've seen a decline in like public interviews that everyone
could see.
Like in 1993 for example,
you know Larry King Live interview between Ross Perot in Vice President Al Gore
about Nafta.
But it's things like the transpacific partnership,
much bigger in scope.
We've had no public debate or discussion.
So my question is like,
is there a risk of social media being a self selection kind of filter where you
only get the information you want to hear and everything else has asked a great
question.
Yes.
And I think in part the good news,
like this year,
look at the TV ratings for the debates are through the roof.
They're higher than they've ever been because there's so few moments like that
where there aren't those kinds of shows where you have this live interaction,
unedited,
unsupervised,
and just go at it and,
and I think that that's,
I think that's a really,
I think that's a really good point.
When I,
you know,
when I said that all social media,
I mean I think it's like she said in the film,
are you using it to watch the Kardashians or are using it for all the good that
it,
it could do for you.
I mean,
to test my theory,
I had been walking around my neighborhood about political topics and making
comics and flyers and just talking to people and everyone tells me I'm just
wasting my time and I should be going on social media instead.
Oh No,
I don't.
No,
no,
no.
Because,
because social media can also just be noise.
There's so much noise.
What you're doing,
having that personal human interaction.
We're social beings.
It's why nothing has killed the movies.
The movie theaters won't go away.
The way record stores and video stores went away.
Theaters won't go away.
That's because people want to be with other people.
It's why restaurants will never go away.
Nobody says the restaurant's survive.
Everybody's got a kitchen in their home now.
Well,
because they like to go out and they'd like to be around strangers and eating in
front of strangers.
That's who we are as humans.
And we want to sit in a dark room with 200 other people.
You know,
you can't,
you can't.
The video store that was,
you were taking that home to watch.
Sometimes by yourself,
you know,
or the,
the record or the CD you are putting in your ears.
That's not the movies.
So in fact,
I honestly,
I'm,
uh,
I'm very anti watching a movie on that laptop or on your phone.
You are not watching a movie.
If you're watching it on your phone,
you're watching something,
you know.
But as the filmmaker,
it's not the way I intended.
I made this to be seen on a big screen.
You know,
I,
I meant it to be experienced socially,
not,
not personally.
You know,
it's,
you can watch Lawrence of Arabia,
you know,
or the current star wars on your phone,
but you're not watching star wars.
You know,
you're not,
that's not the way they intended it to be seen.
Um,
the u s postal service issued the Mona Lisa stamp many years ago.
That was not the Mona Lisa.
That was a stamp with the Mona Lisa and the staff.
We're a depiction of the Mona Lisa on the stamp,
but that you have not seen the Mona Lisa unless you go to that museum in Paris.
So,
so you have not seen my movie.
If you've watched it on an iPhone or on a computer screen or even on a TV
screen,
that's just not the way you need to go out to the movies.
You need to go into a movie theater.
And,
and I'm,
I feel very passionate about this.
In fact,
I,
I have restored movie theaters in Michigan and I set them up as nonprofits and
run them and I program them and went and I have really just one rule.
Other than that everybody should be able to buy soda and popcorn for $2.
That's like,
that's like rule one,
don't rip people off.
And uh,
the second rule is if you're caught on your cell phone during the movie,
you're banned from the theater for life
is it really works.
Wow.
You know,
because I'm,
because this is not the place for that.
As much as I am a proponent of the devices and technology and social media or
whatever that is,
just,
you know,
I read some crazy statistic that 17% of guys admit to having looked over at
their phone during sex.
What's,
Woo.
Wow.
What's going on?
You're looking at me like I'm guilty.
Like my fiance just called.
He was like,
so Kevin,
I'm just,
I don't understand.
I don't understand that.
I don't,
I don't know.
I don't want us to become that stay human,
use these things like she said for the good but,
but stay human.
That's a two more.
Um,
I,
I'm an American,
uh,
clearly who,
um,
started traveling abroad a lot several years ago and it took me a long time to
like stop thinking America was the best at everything and to like become less
defensive and be able to take criticism and be open minded.
And I wonder like,
how can Michael Moore make a movie that would like actually speak to the
Republicans and get them to learn what like what me as a sort of a democrat or
an open minded person would get from this.
I made it.
It's this movie.
They've already,
the studio was already tested it amongst conservatives.
Really?
Yeah.
Now I'm not talking about the 20% that are way over here on the,
uh,
on the,
you know,
the far right.
They're kind of lost souls.
Okay.
It'd be,
you know,
the people that believe that Adam and eve rode on dinosaurs 6,000 years ago.
God bless them,
but I,
I can't help them,
but there's a whole bunch in here,
you know,
the who call themselves conservatives,
but they actually believe if women are doing the same work,
they should be paid the same amount of money and they want to drink clean water
and breathe clean air and they want their kids to go to really good schools and
you know,
they're there for,
they're for a lot of good things.
Uh,
they just don't like being taxed.
They don't like sharing their money with other people.
They hate the poor,
you know,
like it's a disease.
Right.
But they,
but on a lot of,
but they,
at least we'll have an open mind.
And they,
they did,
they've tested this and it's tested.
I went to a screening out in Westport,
Connecticut a couple of weeks ago and then I talked to the Republicans in the
room afterwards and then we went out to a bar after that.
And it was amazing the amount of epiphany's that these Republicans had watching
this.
First of all,
it's the first film of mine they've seen because they've been told not to see
the others.
Right.
And I,
and I've,
and I always tell a Republican,
I said,
you know,
I don't want you to change your mind,
but if you'll just watch any of my films,
you'll know three things right away.
I love this country.
I have a heart and you're going to laugh at least a half a dozen times during
the movie.
I can guarantee you those three things.
And you don't have to change your politics at the end of it,
but maybe it'll make you think a little bit about some things.
So,
and,
and like you say,
you,
you reached that point where you realize we're not number one at everything.
We're not the greatest thing ever invented.
Right?
But you love this country.
Yeah.
You don't want to live anywhere else.
Well,
well,
after watching this,
we're watching this movie.
You can't leave.
You have to stay and help make it better.
Sorry,
one quick one.
I'm not sure if it's a quick one,
but,
um,
first of all,
I live in Westport Connecticut.
So I can relate to that.
And second of all,
it's great that he make all of his movies.
I love them and a lot of fathers and it just went to watch spike Lee's Shira.
And I was really impressed with the movie and I wish more people would watch it,
but the pharaoh was how Pham Te and Vanessa was an opening weekend.
And the Tarot is really small to be honest.
So my question is,
movies are awesome and the open ended articles are great,
but beyond the movies,
how do we reach that maybe 80% 90% of the population who just too busy to watch
the movies or to,
to to more consumers,
more concerned with,
you know,
making the ends meet and feed the family.
Well,
that's a problem.
All art suffers.
All art suffers when the majority of the population is living from paycheck to
paycheck.
That story last week,
that,
that the majority of Americans now,
the majority of Americans,
if they had an emergency,
don't have $400 if they needed $400 tonight,
they have it nowhere.
They'd have to sell something or borrow it.
Yeah.
Well,
you've got so many people working a second job.
The Germans laughing at me there.
The idea of a second job is insane to them.
Right?
So how do you get those people to actually start?
We have to fix the economic system in this country that is driving people's
heads into the ground.
That's what,
that's what we have to stop this massive transfer of wealth to the upper 0.1%
because it's making everybody else scrambled so hard and worry for their
survival that they don't have time to go to the movies or write that poem or
sing that song.
And we've made our,
our entertainment.
So out of the reach of working people,
what's across to go to a Knicks game,
what's it called?
I went to youtube last summer.
There was $280 you know,
what's it,
what's it cost to the,
I mean,
the movies are the last place and even that's,
it's too much.
You know,
I don't charge more than $8 and 50 cents at my theater and that,
and that includes three d,
no extra charge.
That's a rip off.
You know,
I don't charge you more money because the movies three hours instead of two
hours or two hours instead of 90 minutes,
you know,
but that's what has to change.
There's the,
the,
the oligarchy,
the people that exist at the top that are running the show,
the small number of people that own 90% of the wealth in this country are
setting it up.
So the rest of us just can't frigging enjoy life.
And that has to change.
That has to change it.
It can change.
We can make a change legally too,
you know,
at that would,
that would just require
a Bernie Sanders.
Imagine him as president.
You know,
it's not an endorsement.
I'm just saying,
I like Hillary.
I'm just saying not going to change with Hillary.
Then again,
she could end up being our Pope Francis.
Like where did that come from?
All of a sudden there's a popup that says,
you know,
gay people aren't going to burn in hell.
So,
you know,
things can change,
things get better.
But I,
I really believe that,
um,
this is a great question.
You've raised that,
that the theater would be half empty for spikes film such an important movie.
And,
but my question maybe to you,
all of you and you have sex in strange ways,
distracted or we call it distractive sex.
Yes.
But how do you,
Michael Moore just tweeted,
we're going to edit all this out.
Um,
but no,
but I would like to,
I'd ask
you,
your generation,
this is the generation where you're not going to the theater as much to watch
movies.
Yeah.
You know,
why is that?
Why?
I mean,
it's a quiet,
it's not a philosophical question.
I mean,
it's lazy,
just lazy.
It's,
he,
it's easier to get them.
It's easier to watch it on the computer.
It's,
it's easier.
A Tan,
easily attainable.
Easily attainable.
Yeah.
And,
but there are some,
I think at least,
I don't know what category it falls into,
but for me personally,
there are some films where I will actively go out and see them because I'm like,
I need to see that on the big screen.
And some I'm just like,
I can wait.
All right.
So for an action film,
you want to see that on a big screen,
you want to see everything right.
But for this you want to see this with other people,
it wasn't this a different experience that plays into it as well that plays here
for sure.
Or maybe the movies just aren't as good anymore.
Maybe there's just too much crap out there when everything's a franchise and,
right.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and so which means that your generation,
we're not seeing but the next cool break or the next Scorsese over the next,
you know,
whatever,
we're not seeing enough of the good films made by people in their twenties and
thirties.
Well and uh,
I know we have to wrap up,
but just one final point cause it was really,
really important and it was one of my favorite moments in the film as well,
was in Iceland,
the first woman president who really inspired so many young women and girls to
kind of grow up and actually be more than what,
you know,
society,
it kind of painted them to be Welch.
Oh these are only men's jobs or whatever.
And one of the most incredible things was the company boards.
It's by law that they have to be at least 40% women or 40% men.
It could be 60% women and 40% men,
or it could be 60% men and 40% of women,
but it has to be that.
And um,
you know,
she had said once you have three women in the boardroom,
that's when culture starts changing.
One is just a token to as a minority and three is when the group dynamics really
start changing.
So is that,
could that be something that is a big start in the us of something that we could
do,
um,
to really inspire the change?
Yes.
That would be a great law to pass.
Uh,
Germany's just past the,
there,
there are 30%.
You know,
I think that w I think that we could follow the German way easier than the
Scandinavian or Nordic way.
Um,
but uh,
yes,
obviously the more women in the room,
the better.
We're where did that,
what Jenner?
That's so old.
You don't,
I don't where whoever thought of that idea that women shouldn't be at the table,
it's always better with women around.
Right.
You know,
I,
I mean,
your generation already knows this,
you know,
we,
there are now,
I mean,
there are now more women in college than men there did,
didn't it just last year.
Women in law school surpass men.
Um,
uh,
there are now more when managers have,
you know,
and just the low level business stuff.
I mean,
there's women,
things are already changing.
Your generation has helped to make this change,
but we're going to be better off with,
with women having a,
a strong say,
not a token se,
but a real,
a real strong say.
And that's not the,
I'm not just making a,
like a tried to bundle all women into one group.
Think,
you know,
there's lots of examples of women that have done horrible things.
Well,
a couple of women I know,
but I ain't not a whole lot,
but you know,
I just think that,
that we're all going to be better off in that way.
Weren't your mother's like that then?
Your mother's raise you to believe that whether your men or women,
that,
that it's,
it's crazy to walk into a room and have just a bunch of guys,
you know,
you're never going to get the best work,
the best product,
the best anything.
And in tech,
this is a real issue.
You know,
that you don't want to shut women out of this because that next great invention
then it can great thought's going to come from what they bring to the table that
you don't have as a man,
you know?
Well,
and they're starting to change that mean we have this whole,
you know,
campaign with made with code.
We're starting to teach little girls about in a fun way.
Yeah.
They pair it up with,
you know,
Pixar and Disney to do the made with code campaign and with inside out and
stuff.
So it was,
it was really good to kind of get these girls when they're young,
instead of say,
hey,
you can also be an engineer.
Hey,
you could do this and kind of teach him any young age.
So they're just not trying to figure it out when they're older.
Yeah,
I think,
I think that,
I hope that came through in the film that I really remember,
sure.
Big Believer in this and that and that will have a better world when it's,
when it's a shared world and not just not just you and I because you know,
we have,
we have a y chromosome and not the second x,
it would have been an x,
but one of the quadrants fell off.
Making an a why?
It's my,
it's my firm belief that that missing part of our second x has the volume
control,
has the ability to ask for directions,
aesthetics.
Uh,
you know,
there's a whole bunch of things that,
why,
why do women do better on the sats that's in there somewhere.
So I think,
um,
and I just want to say before we close to the,
your,
your main,
your main dude here,
Larry.
Larry patient.
The Godfather yes.
Of,
of Google is a Michigander is from Michigan.
Anybody knew that and everybody know that in here.
Yes.
Um,
so just another great thing that we've,
we've given the world.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible] February 12th,
February 12th,
and that's right in the middle of the,
uh,
election cycle.
Yes.
Uh,
yes,
we are.
We,
we were in theaters during the week of the New Hampshire primary.
Thank you so much,
Michael.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[inaudible].